he's definitely there or thereabouts but
sometimes after some difficult games he
struggles to bounce back uh-huh if he
has one or two bad losses
often he writes off the tournament so um
yep sam he's one of the best players out
there these days but still maybe less
consistent than some of the top top guys
you know i on that subject i have seen
um
i saw at the american championships uh
that sam pulled out a number this during
the player's draw for the opening
ceremony he pulled out a number that he
didn't want and he was like so visibly
angry and upset with himself and he was
like it kind of felt like he'd already
decided then it was not going to be a
good tournament for him just because he
pulled out the wrong number yeah cool
it's all about the details he just is
his life and it always has been um for
sam franklin meanwhile it's the italian
game uh one of the most popular openings
these days uh in elite circles and a
very topical position here this is
very well known this type of position
it's just quite quiet all the pawns all
the pieces on the board but it will
liven up later
the italian game that's one thing that
when i was young uh it didn't have maybe
the best reputation it was regarded as
kind of a lazy person's opening and then
all these new ideas were discovered in
the last 10 years alone and everybody's
playing it with both colours
it's very rich and very dynamic
so sam's done
some of the best chessable course as
well some of the best received and it
looks like he's getting ready to film
another one there he's got the he's got
the green screen already so it's like
right maybe that's why he's a bit angry
it's like this is getting the way of my
chess ball recording hey yeah he's
getting of course out he has so many he
has d4 sicilian berlin semi slav i know
he has another one coming out as well
yeah then they're really well very good
reviews on all of them i mean he's such
a dedicated opening researcher that um
they're only going to be good material
what what he does coming for your record
of 27 chessable courses simon
he's got a long way to go there
a long way to go yet so yeah do you have
any more testable courses in the
pipeline probably yeah you have just i
just breed them
i just breed chess ball not not kids
chess ball courses
you have though ivanka you have
something you're talking about maybe
making a chessable course
maybe
um
yeah i mean we haven't quite worked out
the details
yeah i can imagine that would be you
something you would do really well at
checking chess having a good chestable
course yeah i mean it's a lot of fun
yeah the only thing is that a
lot of work as well yeah that's true so
uh yeah i mean
the great thing about doing these type
of courses is that's so fantastic for
your chest because in order to
communicate something effectively you
actually have to understand it very well
and
that's that's something that they say
when you want to break down information
or when you have something very
complicated the best thing you can do
you know and also to get it to stick
into your memory is actually to teach it
to someone low rated than you and if
they can understand it then okay you're
doing a good job yeah and sam shanklin
when all his chestable courses well he
must be expert in many parts of the game
and many openings david that's right and
sam is also an exception because he
practices what he preaches whatever
chessboard course he makes he will play
it he will use his own games as
kind of the foundation for those
stressful courses and
okay in this one we've seen a lot of
trades
all of the bishops about to leave the
board
and the main imbalance is that black has
doubled e pawns if you look in front of
the black king on the e file black has
doubled pawns there so long term maybe a
weakness
black lacks flexibility with his central
pawns but
it's a minimal thing right now
especially while queens and major pieces
remain
so okay mishra
i'm wondering what he's thinking about
usually you want to take this bishop
back with your knight
and uh yeah it's just very very tense
there's a lot of life left a lot of
maneuvering maybe ahead it's incredible
now if you think about it how all these
players playing here they have a course
out you know if you go back like you
know 50 years can you just imagine all
the guys having a video course out and
still playing you know i sure would
never share secrets yeah exactly bobby
fischer with his you know chess ball
courseways playing or it's just it's a
different world isn't it really that you
can get so much information uh at any
level you know quickly but is it almost
like writing a book because i know it's
a lot of work there's hours and hours of
video yeah definitely yeah i mean it's
it's just as hard i'd say as writing a
book because you've got to write it
check the lines and then present the
course as well and you've got to present
it in a way that um people understand it
so uh so it's it's there's a lot of
elements to doing it yeah and carl i
suspect maybe in prisons that
online stuff such as chesable playing
online that's not the easiest maybe for
the prisoners no because many don't get
access to the internet for obvious
reasons and so that's where books come
in still there is a need for books of
course and magazines and
it's very useful i'm thinking about i
don't know if gary casper i've ever did
a chestable course i don't know but i do
remember the first vhs videos that came
out
what the exactly
i'm here to take you back vhs
explaining what you're thinking to
people
and i can't remember the opponent and
somebody was interviewing him in a game
against karpov and he said well what did
you do here gary he said well it's quite
easy i play bishop f2 or g3 i play
knight f5 g4 g5 and it's just big
advantage and win
and the guy said to him well could you
please just explain that for the
audience
no
no
it's just obvious win and i paid 15
pounds for that i think well
so you know you have to have a talent
you can be as good as you want but you
know
tell us gary we've paid the money so
that's where nowadays this is just
invaluable
uh not everyone can teach i guess yeah
not even the best player in the world at
the time i mean
in some ways i mean yeah
just uh confusing sometimes so yeah sees
too much
yeah and uh i mean you mentioned books
kaya i think the
biggest kind of successful period of sam
shanklin's career was just after he
wrote a few books on uh pawn structures
and then i think within months he became
american champion ahead of those players
caruana so nakamura
so yeah i think as you haven't mentioned
putting the work in creating chessable
courses creating books
that's actually the modern way of
improving and working on one's game why
just spend hours you know tapping with a
computer passively just like trying to
memorize
why not actively try and write things
down into words um just trying to kind
of explain your thought processes and
that helps you understand better
i know that's been the case with me for
commentary and with writing
i find i understand chess better than
ever now
but especially better than uh than when
i was young when i was purely
calculating i know when i was young i
couldn't explain why certain moves were
good certain porn structures were good
because i would maybe recognize them but
it's i mean i didn't understand myself
and uh yeah these top players
interesting that's why they understand
so well now and that's why they're able
to communicate their thoughts uh through
modes like chesapore but obviously then
putting all of that stuff out on
chessable uh it is money for for the top
chess players for anyone doing it so
that is a great thing but
it also reveals your strengths
everything you're thinking about
something maybe you found out is that a
problem
at all it's a fine line yeah it's a fine
line but at the same time you know this
information is out there for everyone to
discover because you know after all
everyone is playing chess everyone now
has computers and the top players all
have super computers so i mean i i think
it's a good thing to kind of get your
information out there and uh you know
we
on the tour the last season we had that
fantastic example where wesley also
created a chesable course and he then
won two tournaments on the back of it
yeah and even beat matt i mean he was
just playing his course against magnus
yeah it turns out magnus hadn't done the
research magnus hadn't gone on to
chessable and studied wesley's course
and wesley was just using exactly the
material on there so
it's one thing revealing secrets but
your opponents have extra work to do to
actually go and study those come in and
watch my 10 hour chestable course magnus
carlsen i can remember one grandmaster
telling me a story this is before
chessable courses and books where you
got your information from and they
weren't always correct because computers
weren't as strong i remember his
grandmaster telling me he wrote a book
but he left out the best line so he left
out a winning line in a very complicated
he said well i don't i don't want people
playing this against me so he wrote this
book on it on purpose and then uh but he
left out a winning line so uh so it's a
little bit hidden uh and then uh yeah he
said well he said he got an email from
someone and this guy said well i follow
i followed your book and it's just uh
you know it's just losing what's going
on he's like oh yeah sorry about that
so there was a bit of craftiness before
with some players hiding the lines and
trying to trick readers i mean that
doesn't happen anymore because of
computers but uh
it did happen it did used to happen so
it's still very strange isn't it because
it you know it is a war game
and you're effectively giving away the
details of your military capability why
would you do that
if you still got aspirations to achieve
things why would you do that yeah it's
strange
i understand why sometimes
because there's something wonderful
about having your name
on paper
for everyone to read and for people just
to look at your work i think that's okay
but unless you're aspiring to get
somewhere if you if you're targeted on
on you know becoming a world champ or
something like this
you can do that later yeah this is the
now this i want this i'll give those
details later kasparov would never do it
would he he would have said
he was doing it without his prime you
know there's like kasparov teaches chess
and then there's uh also um
or someone else quite a few players
bobby fischer did my 60 men they weren't
giving away well they didn't give his
big database though true he didn't give
his database away did he
no chance
no
the position meanwhile is still quite
stable still maneuvering but carl um how
about the process of writing your books
was that
i mean how did you kind of come up with
the idea originally and how did you uh
kind of find that one the prism one was
quite easy because i i looked i looked
to see if there was anything like it out
there where can i find information about
chest and prisons and there wasn't this
is back 2014 i started doing it
and then prisoners wrote to me and i
would write certain things when i go
into prisons and i thought why don't i
just put all of this together so that
prisoners can have i'll call it the
chess bible if you like
being sort of self-effacing but
one book that they can learn about the
history of chess the moves the chess
great games you know how to study how to
motivate yourself all those things that
you might want in one book in one cell
and it came together quite easily to be
fair
and so
that was great the other book which is
really my chess memoir yeah this is a
thicker book yeah it's about it's about
how and we must all be able to identify
how chess has helped me through my own
life when i found it when i was 12 years
old i was i didn't achieve anything
until i became school champion and at
that moment you know i knew i could do
something i wasn't the prefect because i
was never really the good boy but i
managed to get an honest tie which my
pre-vet frame could never get and i
thought you know what when i stood on
stage that day
when i was 16 and i got the trophy and i
got the tired i could not be more proud
and i still am and it's just a school
title but
it's
everybody has a moment in their life
when they know they can do something
achieve something and that's the same
for the prisoners as well so you just
got to keep believing in yourself and
working at it you need a bit of luck as
well i have to say this cole's story is
absolutely fantastic it's a rip-roaring
tale and sometimes your jaw will drop
when you read about the adventures that
carl has had in his life and looking
forward to reading it and i can see
there's few chess boards in this so it's
not a classical chess book with
all the chess board and the notation no
no it's just uh it's just almost like a
novel
very cool
all right and uh well the big moments is
in this game is that coming up david i
hope so because it's been very quiet at
this point and maybe we can jump in to
just discuss what is costing the players
so much time on the clock what they're
thinking about what's going on in their
mind and
it's just so stable right now white
pieces are nicely centralized i like
what misha has done with his rooks um
getting ready for the position to open
up the knights are pretty good right now
the white queen as well on a nice decent
active square
maybe creating some annoying pressure on
this diagonal the problem though for
mishra is what to do next sometimes in
chess your position is just too nice and
it's hard to improve
one
concept would be maybe pushing forward
in the center with your pawns opening up
the position but are you ready that's
the big question we might well see a
trade a capture of pawns here and now
the question is if you take with the
knight we'll see the knights come off
the board maybe the queens will come off
the board next everything will get
traded off
but if you take with the pawn this is a
porn sacrifice and uh black will capture
your pawn in the middle of the board you
just aren't ready and therefore mishra
says okay i'm not ready i'm gonna
retreat and
that's the thing in chess it's so hard
for a human to just sit still do nothing
and uh wait for the action to happen he
stepped back with his knight it's very
hard for mishra to sit still wasn't it
yeah i mean he's he's cool
yeah
uh instead he's worsened his knight at
least temporarily maybe he'll improve on
the next move by bringing it next to its
fellow knight guard his king
but
yeah it's so hard to imagine any real
progress being made i like what sam's
done actually black is rock solid and
i'm expecting him to bring his other
rook to this f-file and actually with
black you could
potentially create some attack
another idea would be to bring your
knight to the edge of the board this is
uh quite a common plan at all levels i
know when i was young
when i was kind of an amateur player and
uh just get coming through the ranks i
dreamt of putting a knight on this
square just
kind of the building uh building the
bridges for an attack later on and uh
yeah lots of choice black's pawn
structure is the only real imbalance
this double pawns but they're not a
weakness at least for now and uh do you
want to know a fun fact
so we were talking about chessboard
courses sam shanklin he has four of them
his thoughts his plans all out there on
chesabol and stop me of course david if
something shocking happens but mishra so
this is a message from gadit from
chesable and he writes to me and says
mishra became a grandmaster by switching
from playing one e4 to one d4 and the
the report char he used to attain his
grandmaster title was sam shanklin's
chesable course
lifetime repertoire is 1d4 and mishra
also started playing shanklin's uh
semi-slav versus black against 1d4 so if
anyone knows shanklin's repertoire it's
mishra
yeah
that much because you know when i was
looking at mishra's games well actually
that's not the story the story is i was
actually using sam shanklin's repertoire
myself and there was a lot of abby manu
mishra's games i was like oh
someone has been watching shangler
snapchat and yeah the opening he used in
the last game against magnus that was
something sam shanklin had played before
as well so
um yeah that must be unsettling for sam
every time he researches his own
openings he says he sees mishra's name
so maybe that's why sam is playing
something that i haven't actually seen
him play before
um but he's also got his own course out
i think mishra as well chess ball so
it's worth if you want to know how this
kid became the youngest grandmaster ever
he's got a chess ball course where he
talks about that so that's also very
interesting i think for the sparring
players yeah it's funny you mentioned uh
he became a grand master from switching
from one e4 to d4 here he switched back
to one e4 but he's finally played d4 not
a move one move 18.
perfect timing actually
and they're talking about courses i just
want to read out one comment from elmer
johnson who has a kind of comment aimed
at simon who says simon
you made the black lion where is the
white tiger the blue elephant the green
dragonfly and the rest of the unusually
colored animal courses in production
give it another couple of weeks i'll be
in your email so 27 new courses
we actually just funnily enough it's
funny a new course came out yesterday uh
can you believe it you were talking
about it and i think we it was kind of
one i did jointly but it was one of the
ones i'm happiest about it wasn't my
course it was uh one i did with keith
arcol
and it's really keith arkhav's course
on um how he became such an amazing
endgame player
and it's a very interesting course
because
it avoids variations so i get really
bored with i'll be honest long
variations that you can't i can't be
doing with them i like simple
explanations about why did you do this
why did you do that so keith's keys
course our carl's endings um we should
just come out and chest ball is is i
think a really good way to become as as
you said
all-round player wasn't it not just an
opening player but a a rounded player so
yeah that's course number 20.
there are golden nuggets in there i just
saw keith at the english championships a
couple of weeks ago and
i said to him i'd read the book at the
first point was the book and
little nuggets like at what point in an
end game does he move his f-pawn you've
got this point i never move my f-pawn
until a certain point which you'll have
to look at the cause to understand but
you know those little nuggets but when
you're a
just a normal tournament player like me
you then have to understand how you
proceed from there but it's it's all
they've given away all this information
take it
be the greatest gameplay in british
history yeah or one of the top three
really that's what he's known for yeah
certainly he's a great end-game play and
he's basically made a career from it you
know since he was a kid uh to to where
he is now he's just one ending so that's
that's made his life you know his house
and everything right it's just the same
game over and over again yeah he wins
every time i don't have his time
computer always says computer always has
0.0500 moves yeah and then a few minutes
later he wins and it's always the same
kind of idea so he's put it in it he's
put it in a course now that's the thing
he's actually put those ideas he just
does the same setup the same ideas same
way exactly it's amazing did you know
something i actually have seen uh some
of keith's attacks amazing and they're
ferocious yeah uh absolutely some
fantastic games from him yeah his thing
is to be a great endgame player you have
to calculate really really well firstly
to survive to the end game but uh even
a9 games to finish things off it's all
about calculation the last stage um so
yeah he's he can do everything yeah his
game against julian hodgson actually uh
is in that course he he had a win where
he crushed julian hodson in like 25
moves when julian hodson i think was one
of the top 20 players in the world so it
does have uh the older tacky game in
there as well what was the name of this
course our carl's endings i am after
after keith
and this is the this is the course for
me not that i make it too many end games
but if i do yeah it's
a nice easy easy like to not too many
deep deep lines but just explanations so
yeah
and talking of explanations a couple of
things have happened in the game so
maybe we should jump in um to show and a
big moment now for sam shankland he's
thinking um just to rewind we left it in
this position black had just doubled up
the rooks actually some attacking
potential here along this line for black
so mishra thought okay it's time to
clarify the situation no time to wait
anymore um hint he pushed his pawn
forward we saw a trade in the center and
knights came off the board as well and
now the queens are staring down at each
other it's black's move the shanklings
move does he trade
he allows the exchange to happen i was
going to say if he wants to win this
game then maybe he can keep the queens
on just move the queen out of the way
next move you can move your knight and
the black rooks do have attacking
potential on this line but okay he
chooses in
this moment to push in the center i
trust him because he's great at kind of
navigating pawn structures but this does
allow white to push forward and block
things up also white when to trade when
not to trade the tension might continue
for a while
just to explain to viewers at home it
looks like this is quite a good
trade for black in this situation white
has doubled isolated pawns now but this
one white pawn completely locks down
this black pawn this black pawn now is a
backward pawn because any time it
marches forward one squares or two
squares it's just going to be captured
by the white pawn on passant even
so this is a backward pawn for eternity
and it's actually quite hard to mobilize
it later so uh interesting decision in
terms of pawn stretches
worsening your opponent's pawn structure
but also uh worsening your own in the
process so instead pushing this pawn
forward i'm expecting mishra to do the
same lock things up and we'll see a
situation where white has more space in
the center but this block structure
means it's all about maneuvering
and whose night is going to be better
that's the big question
interesting
thinking he is down to seven minutes
they played uh equally fast these two
players in this game and will we have a
winner or will it be a draw
i don't know i think all three results
are possible and it's actually probably
going to hinge on this next few moves
because uh the line that david showed to
me looked nice for white but uh if abby
manu plays inaccurately you know and
somehow you know there's the queens get
traded off and black is allowed to be
very mobile with his pawns on the left
side of the board i think maybe sam
shanklin could be better so a critical
moment in the game
yeah it's all it's not going to swing in
just one move it's all going to be about
long-term planning it's going to be a
series of small inaccuracies from one
side maybe
okay this exchange of pawns makes some
sense as well but now after black
recaptures for example if black takes
this pawn back with his own pawn white
is left with an isolated pawn in the
center of the board so long term i
wasn't so keen on this one
so rather i'm unambitious i feel this
move because uh you're making exchanges
and you could have grabbed some more
space by just pushing forwards
controlling more squares and it seems
like this is uh trying trying to
simplify things a little too much to my
liking
uh here so he has done that a couple of
times mishra even when he was winning
yesterday against ding for example he's
trying to take the most simple option
um maybe that's just a natural thing i
think i did the same when i was young
facing opponents rated 200 points higher
um okay the queens do finally come off
and now
after this capture with the black knight
okay interesting now both sides have
weaknesses blacks ruxo have opened up so
black's rooks are threatening to come
down and take white's pawn on the f2
square
i think that paul needs to push or be
defended
black does however have an isolated pawn
of his own on the e6 square a target for
white's rook in the center
weaknesses everywhere yeah that's true
normally i kind of judge these type of
positions by doing some simple maths i'm
like black has one weakness
that's the pawn on e6
white on the other hand has three pawns
with no friends
and those guys could be well vulnerable
yeah
targeted two white b pawns i mentioned
they did clamp down on one of black
spawns but those two white b pawns
yeah if black knight can hop around
maybe and
start attacking them they could be
difficult to defend so long term i could
definitely see this going wrong for
white
and uh okay mishra he's not too far
behind on the clock for now so okay
keeping his pawns nice and safe blocking
the black crooks that's a good start
yeah so you mentioned david sam shanklin
he is a former uh u.s
champion has has mishra even started
playing those u.s championships i think
he's been playing in uh different
sections of the us championship there
are junior tournaments uh and qualifying
events but the us championship itself
it's very elite it's just the top 10 or
12 players okay we lost the players
there
they're coming back um but yeah you have
to qualify for the us championship
either by rating or through kind of a
process of other events okay so
it might be a few years before mishra
can compete unfortunately in the u.s
there are just so many players i think
you need to be
2650
rating wise 26.50 at least to qualify
maybe even closer to 2 700 these days
wow i'm not sure i'd even get into the
u.s championship
it's uh that strong these days yeah and
how about in england all of you
are english superstars are there any
english youngsters coming
up that you are a little bit excited
about that everyone is paying a little
bit extra attention to
this one
shreyas royal um i don't know how old he
is david knows him a lot better than i
do but he's basically the same age as
abu emmanuel mishra and
um he's not as far along in the
development process but he's almost
international master level okay um so
maybe in a few years he'll be
grandmaster and uh take it from there
yeah to be honest there's not enough i
mean if you compare it to other
countries uh compared to india
uzbekistan yeah
pakistan as well yeah
china i mean if you go back to the 1970s
i mean 80s england were like number two
in the world pretty much i mean they
came second in the olympiad and it has
to be said since then i mean we have
some great players don't get me wrong
some really good i mean players young
players i mean you know you're friends
with marcus harvey but he's not a junior
anymore a very talented player but we we
don't really have enough coming through
i would compared to other countries it's
just not there the sad fact of the
matter is that uh we just don't have
enough funding
and uh you know a lot of these countries
like for instance uzbekistan you know
the government is actually pumping in
like millions of dollars
to aid their chess players meanwhile in
the uk you know we're struggling on
travel to tournaments maybe yeah it's a
struggle it's all self-funded really
that's the thing if you want to become a
good player in england since we were
juniors even i mean we had to get
support from our parents uh which is
massive you know costs a lot of money to
go to tournaments and you don't really
never really be much government support
or or support elsewhere from sponsors
imagine abductor of when he won the
world rapid championship
um the president of uzbekistan gave him
a free apartment yeah i mean and a huge
chunk of cash uh to support his
development so that would never happen
in the uk england
johnson given us your wallet and well if
there is not you know
right now a big prodigy coming up uh
we did talk a little bit before the show
called there could be a very good team
in what was it online world prison
championship
yep correct uh the the second world
prison online chess championships will
be held this october
and you have an english team well there
are malcolm payne and the
chessy schools and communities charity
are running three
i'm trying to run one uh from the middle
of england and um
yeah we're gonna be competing against
rest of the world and it's a mega
opportunity of course for prisoners
imagine
being in prison and saying i've
represented my country at some point
fantastic incredible and that is just
how far up the agenda we seem to be more
doing more in prisons than we do in
schools so you know if we made a really
great player out of prison of course
they couldn't be let out to play but we
we need to get more chess into not just
prisons but schools i have no it's very
contentious but i have no idea why we
don't introduce some into a curriculum
why can't we just do something but
anyway it's just very annoying but
it's where we are there's some one
player who i really want to see play in
the online presence is uh
well recent recent inmate of uh hmp
he plays chess that's true
that would be interesting it would be
great interesting he's actually not he's
quite a decent chess player yes yeah
well i think he played kasparov once and
he went for scholars mate or something
yeah bit so he's maybe not the strongest
but
i mean it's a bit sad isn't it that he's
actually in a tough prison no yeah that
is very sad actually i mean it seemed
right to me but
um yeah
you'll have to bring us up to speed curl
and how your team does yes i mean people
could go to feed a to the feed a website
and look at chess chess
it's called the chest for freedom and
just have a look just go through the
video website have a look at what's
happening there's a guy called mikhail
korenman in in america in the sheriff's
office there sheriff dart as well lots
of characters uh running this and i say
again it's tremendous that around the
world
chess is he's going high up the agenda
that's all i ever wanted was can we get
chess on the prison agenda
and before prisons would say well why we
can't afford to do it and i would
convince them and say you can't afford
not to do it
because you ask what's the purpose of
prison
what is the purpose of prison many
people say just to keep people away no
it's to help people when they come back
out to not go back in again and we do
that through education probably
influence from other people and chess of
course covers the whole spectrum
see there's a move or two coming up here
is anything dramatic happening on the
board it seems like a calm game or okay
it could be it's heading in shanklin's
direction and that's all because of the
pawn structure i mentioned he's written
books on pawn structures and that's
really paying off right now um if we do
jump in and just show what has happened
on the last few turns um it is turning
now i don't think white should have
rushed um there was a moment where
black's knight looked very very strong
but i think you have to play around it i
think you had to bring your own knight
into a strong square instead trading off
this uh the set of knights has
accentuated the weakness of white's
pawns and this move by shankland a
really nice one bringing his rook
forward hitting this weakness uh we
mentioned that white has three
weaknesses here this pawn this pawn and
this pawn which cannot be defended by
other pawns and now after white blocked
trying to exchange rooks shanklinger
said okay i'm allowing the exchange but
on my terms and he brings his rook
across one square staring down at this
isolated pawn so now there's tension for
example a rook trade i don't think helps
uh white at all blackstroke has an easy
path um towards these weaknesses black's
king as well opened up
to run into the center of the board
yet if white doesn't trade rooks if he
takes this pawn instead then black is
simply going to go pawn hunting rook
takes pawn and it's three connected
pawns here
white meanwhile has these two isolated
pawns these big big weaknesses it's
going to be hard to save this one and
this one long term
i mean it's one-sided it's just playing
for two results as we call it in chess
if white defends really well maybe he'll
get a draw but black is the only one who
can really win this game uh-huh
sam shanklin he uh has a bad start to uh
the day he lost both his games so win
here is exactly what he needs it would
would it be mean a lot to to sam do you
think david to qualify for the knockouts
in this strong tournament definitely um
we've mentioned in the past he's his own
uh
oh okay trading works i didn't like this
but he is his own harshest critic uh sam
and anytime he doesn't perform up to
expectations you can see him tweet about
it he beats himself up about it he tries
to push himself even more um but when he
does well which has happened quite a lot
lately um that kind of drives him i
think even more and uh
yeah it's all about confidence with sam
and
this game i think will help boost his
confidence if he does take it and win it
the black king meanwhile um trying to
make its way towards the left side of
the board where all of the targets lie
so it's funny how uh you get different
types of players like sam is a very
emotional player and you you get a
number of players like i'd say i'm
probably similar when things are going
well you can use that energy and that
energy you know transforms onto your
moves on the ball but when things are
going badly it can have a very negative
effect and we saw magnus in the last
game last round he's maybe the opposite
he can bounce back you know he can put
his emotions aside so it can be a
strength and certainly a weakness at the
same time uh you know and it's trying to
control that and that's again something
that chess
chess does
it makes you control that um i i know
that some of my videos are in some
prisons as well so my youtube videos
some some guys have got their hands on
that's when i received a letter from a
man who said i've been watching mr
williams's dvds or something i don't
know how they did it but they do stream
simon's work into some cells
so he's he's there like a ghost in the
night sometimes and of course the noisy
places aren't they prison so sometimes
they say i was awake all night with the
noise in the next cell it's simon
talking about harry the h pawn
keeping our prison population awake yeah
it's quite a weird fool isn't it you
know
they all know you know yeah yeah i know
they're big in prisons one time i went
in i was playing a simultaneous at some
point i played h4 and everyone was like
harry howard
very cool
inspiring for everyone simon i don't
know meanwhile a lot of moves and
actually white rookers managed to get
active very active taking a pawn but
blackstroke equally active and now it's
all about the quality of pawns black's a
porn it's not about harry now it's about
alice the aporn marching down it's only
a few squares away from promotion and
how does white's rook get back to stop
it
i think this is very dangerous now white
pawns meanwhile it's hard to push them
forward they'll just get traded off no
past pawns for white in this position
but black does have the best pawn and
that's the a pawn watch out for that a5
pawn running down the board white's king
at some point is going to have to
retreat but uh black's rook as well is
okay i like this decision at least
trying to go active giving up a pawn in
the process if black takes this pawn
with his own pawn the white king does
have a route
forward
but uh there is a check though i mean
i was thinking about this move as well
and i was like yeah you know pawn takes
like you say the white king steps
forward but the rick jackson
yeah you're just giving up a pawn so say
takes then this is very nice for white
suddenly you can jump into the position
you can start grabbing some pawns maybe
even some checkmating threats for
example here white rook wants to come up
and trap the black king and the white
king keeps it
under guard but unfortunately this check
is very annoying and you're going to
take this pawn back with a black rook
very confusing these endings though
because i mean i i've i think mishra has
done a very good job
in a very tricky position he's trying to
activate even if he gives away a pawn or
two that is one of the most important
things in in a in a rook ending just to
get active for your rook and your king
he's managing to do that and uh it's a
little bit murky right i mean i think
you have to go for this pawn if you're
in time and you've got to pass pawn
yourself now
bit murky a little bit murky maybe i was
a little bit afraid of this i thought
maybe the king should kind of keep an
eye on alice the a pawn and the white
rook should be the one
like trying to
source some
yeah the king definitely needed to stay
uh just within uh range of this pawn
because uh in this position at least you
can go active with your rook you can
start grabbing some stuff in the current
position if we fast forward what's
happened is that white's king has gone
after this pawn but
still i mean this guy is going to start
running at some point you can start
giving a check maybe you can win
immediately here with some some clever
idea of just trying to swap rooks off at
some point yeah there we see actually
stockfish the computer does confirm
black has one move that's winning
outright
the others maybe give white a chance and
uh it's actually the most obvious move
in the position i feel just a check and
next move grabbing this pawn for example
wherever the white king goes you take
and
i mean these three connected pawns are
gonna win the game white does have one
hope and that's this guy but it does
feel a bit slow black's king at the very
least will slide across and start
guarding against it
um yeah it's looking good for sam some
calculation to be done but looking very
very good for black if he finds this
move
but you know actually despite it winning
a material i'm not sure at that human
move
because you know what else there's no
other yeah but somehow it's like the
idea of that uh white pawn advancing and
that's becoming a race
i think by process of elimination black
had no other logical moves um i mean if
you push the black a pawn then the white
rook is actually going to slide back
along the fourth rank and go and
kind of chase it so i think this was
just
no other option for sam
and we did see pragnanda on fire today
he started the day winning against
magnus carlsen then a draw against
pantalari krishna fellow englishman and
now a win in this round against gwayne
jones so pragnanda currently in second
place in the tournament he has woken up
the 16 year old
and here we go the pawn uh the rook
moving yeah so now it's a race white's f
pawn has to start running nothing else
to do
and black will try and stop that if
black can stop all the white pawns then
black will win with his majority the
black pawns are further away
from white's army than the white pawns
are from black's army so that i think
that's going to be the deciding factor
also the more pawns the better in
general
so shankland in charge and unfortunately
gawain jones your favorite of course
being english he is still struggling he
is in bottom of the table after this
loss as well only two points so far for
wayne
but it is a super strong tournament yeah
very very unfortunate and uh it just
seems like um both gawain and uh his
study partner niels just doesn't seem to
be working because they've actually been
playing the same openings
really interesting uh going jones and
nils they've worked together in the past
they play this tournament they're
playing exactly the same stuff really
also when i played nils gondolas in a
match um just a couple of months ago i
knew instantly that gawain had been all
over the preparation but uh because he
knows me so well on from the english
chess circuit he had been supplying nils
with ideas
um so it's interesting but yeah
unfortunately not going so well in this
tournament for them no
and uh okay white's rook has to take a
step back just guarding the third rank
stopping black's a pawn from continuing
its advance
look how much more exciting the end game
is compared to the opening exactly this
is where the thrills begin and the
roller coaster yeah it's all about races
yeah this is the fun bit this is where
everybody stands around the board and
looks when you're playing your game they
don't stand around in the opening i mean
look look at the pulsating head there
it's all going on the veins popping
absolutely you can definitely see it on
sam he is interested in this position
right now leaning forwards is he also
talking to himself a little bit i think
sam does that i've played him many times
over the board and he's always kind of
encouraging himself
it's like you see tennis players shout
like come on yeah he's doing that to
himself quite often i mean isn't there a
straightforward way how to kind of push
that
a pawn through to its destination i was
thinking move the rook
two squares
okay challenge rooks yes offer a trade
and that's what sam's calculating
blackstroke can come down and uh fight
for the third rank
it's either very very good or it's a
mistake and he plays it he plays it
very natural if we see a rook trade now
if white's rock goes and captures the
black rook black pawn is quicker than
white f pawn
yeah i think you're right ivanka it's
just logical maybe white's gonna queen
this way though at least you know that
gives him some chances i guess i mean
just okay you just gotta just count how
many squares it takes to queen let's
let's say the white just pushes the pawn
now uh both sides might might queen
let's say we trade rooks yeah and then
it's a race change for example okay we
didn't do it okay now here it would have
been three two squares away for black
but also two squares away for white and
we see a new set of queens on the board
but at the very end black has these two
pawns so black should win this game uh
maybe with this in mind mishra decided
to keep rooks on but
now in this position black's pawns are
going to start rolling
such a nice move from sam shanklin there
just to give a check force the king onto
a very inconvenient square look at it
it's from in front of its own pawn yep
white's king did not want to walk in
this path actually i've noticed in rook
and games checks are nearly always a
good idea people forget them sometimes
they get too focused on pushing pawns
but checks are now yeah white's pawn is
too far away black's pawns are simply
going to win the game and here we go
it's not only the a pawn but once once
the white rook comes back the b pawn is
going to join it
this one's almost game over now
13
for abby manu to try to find a defense
which is
going to be difficult because it's not
there okay but i like this move you know
well you know if freddie the f pawn
can't move utilize
is it gary gary the g point gary the g
pawn yep gotta push him and i noticed in
magnus's win against mishra actually it
was the h pawn that won the game but it
started as gary it became harry and one
oh
so a bit of a name change there uh-huh
but uh yeah yeah when gary met harry
gary met harry
do you think sam will sort of celebrate
uh in any way with uh winning this game
or will he be very calm he often
celebrates yeah he's got to give it a
little celebrate hasn't he
you have to enjoy your victories i mean
it's it's such a big psychological
mistake just to kind of you know treat
your victories with no emotion yeah
you've got to encourage the
physiological reaction
happiness i remember once i probably
said this before was
i i remember losing to a very strong
player when i was leading this
tournament and uh he started celebrating
very
like basically i was leaning the tour i
was a big tournament and his girlfriend
came over and they started kissing and
like
oh my god just go away
i don't want to see this you know you've
lost an important game so i think you
know in a real tournament situation you
should probably do it away from the
opponent yeah you shouldn't be like get
in there you know it's just have a bit
of respect so i feel yeah
but you know i'm kind of sometimes you
know you get so accustomed to winning
that you feel nothing and i think that
that's wrong i think you have to it's
okay you have to acknowledge you know
that your victories mean something
regardless of who you're playing against
yeah that's my one problem with the top
chess players in the world even when
they win they're never happy um and okay
here we go white pawn is one square away
from promoting but black's rook can do
the dirty work and it goes all the way
back to stop the white pawn black's rook
is actually just going to give itself up
for gary the g pawn and blacks 2
will break through the white rook
um black's just going to make a new
queen and nothing much to do
unfortunately the black rook can just go
away here um any safe square
along the eighth rank and white is
powerless
white's h pawn just too far away and
yeah black has won this race
not much else to say unfortunately no
that's it and um yeah a good victory
there so i have to say for mitchell
though he's always spending all his time
he's always playing a few more moves you
know
he's setting some traps you know there
is a trick on the board learning i guess
at least he's learning yeah i think
that's a good thing when you're young
never ever resign because yeah maybe
once every 20 games once every 30 games
your opponent will relax too soon
unfortunately his trap to distract the
black rook doesn't work white makes new
queen but black makes a new queen as
well and there are no checks no safe
checks for white in this position
black has an extra rook
and sam you can see on his face on his
camera he knows he's about to win this
game and remember three points for a win
in the mouthwater champions chess tour
one point four draws zero points four
losses so a win here will take sam to
ten points and that is good news for him
in hopes of qualifying for
knockout also why resign when it's
possible to mouse slip here sam could
now slip his queen
uh you never know
we've seen stranger things happen on the
tour very optimistic
yeah unlikely yeah
i mean it's very simple uh mating
pattern here this is one of the first
checkmating patterns you learn i think
you use the queen and the queen and the
rook they call it either well is it the
law mode
i call it the guillotine quite like the
guillotine saw another name it recently
um the ladder checkmate ladder yeah when
it's done with rooks you can call it the
rook roller